[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est avec vous on est
en direct c'est figaro live et en attend
vos points de vue faut-il rien touché
faut-il allonger le couvre-feu faut-il
un nouveau confinement
faut-il dans ce cas fermer les écoles
c'est la question qu'on vous pose sur le
site du figaro depuis la mi journée elle
est en ligne
on attend votre réponse est celle de
béatrice giblin ce soit bonsoir béatrice
sur sa professeure des universités
spécialiste de géopolitique et
rédactrice en chef de la revue hérodote
dernier numéro sur l'afrique médiane
ainsi au centre d'afrique et et non pas
simplement la centrafrique et le
prochain numéro sera sur le monde arabe
comme d'habitude 100% texte avec
quelques cartes et 100% passionnant et
on est avec alexis brézet bonsoir alexis
mons en face alors directeur des
rédactions du figaro le figaro qui
revient demain sur cette note du
ministère l'intérieur notamment la
possibilité ce qu'il faut faire pour les
demandeurs d'asile puisqu'on est dans
une situation de saturation faut-il les
répartir dans d'autres régions
françaises êtes vous pour être vous
contre on en débat mais d'abord cette
question êtes vous favorable donc à la
fermeture des écoles en cas de
confinement est juste avant le début de
cette émission c'est davantage au nom
pour l'instant sur le site du figaro
alors julie guitare vous mais en
l'article qui dans le chat fait le point
sur les différents scénarios parmi les
hypothèses
il ya d'abord l'extension du couvre-feu
à 18h partisans notamment deux
épidémiologistes antoine flahault à
l'université de genève et arnaud
fontanet à paris c'est sûr pour que ça
représente un frein sur l'épidémie en
fait un couvre feu c'est un confinement
par ciel nocturne et vespérale mais
c'est une forme de confinement et qui
est un peu moins lourde un peu moins
forts comme comme mesure que qu'un
confinement généralisme en mai ce sont
des mesures qui ont une efficacité
sanitaire clair alors il ya beaucoup
d'arguments pour dire que le couvre-feu
et efficace on le tient aussi des
analyses qui sont qui viennent d'être
faites sur le couvre feu qui avait été
mis en place en france fin octobre la
deuxième quinzaine d'octobre qui a eu un
impact sur la circulation du virus
rappelez-vous que on s'était dit que
c'était redescendu très vite une fois
qu'on avait mis en place le confinement
partiel et c'est est redescendu très
vite et ça s'était même amorcé dès le
couvre-feu de la deuxième quinzaine
d'octobre
donc oui le couvre-feu le corps feu à un
effet donc selon arnaud fontaine et puis
il y à l'étonnant au retour du retour au
confinement
comme le docteur jérôme marty
problème c'est quoi
on voit difficilement comment y échapper
on a une variante qui augmentent dans la
présence augmente et mathématiquement il
doit prendre la place de l'autre c'est
évident n'oubliez pas que sa croissance
est exponentielle et comme il est plus
contaminant chaque fois qu'une personne
est contaminée par celui-ci alban
contaminés et d'autres de façon beaucoup
plus rapide et donc on va voir se
trouvait sur un ciel beaucoup plus tôt
que ce qu'elle était attendu qu'on a on
a un effet double qui risque de nous
amener oui à ce confinement
alors la meilleure solution
on côté heureusement je suis pas en
charge de cette question parce que
franchement c'est un vrai casse tête
on annoncera le confinement de main tout
le monde hurle ray en disant mais
l'économie est absolument c'est
catastrophique bon dire mission confine
tôt on va tout bloquer et puis quinze
jours de confinement puis après ça ira
mieux mais on sait très bien qu après
quinze jours de confinement peut
parfaitement avoir de nouveau un virus
qui circule extrêmement rapidement
bon donc je pense que pour l'instant aux
vues je pense que la décision elle se
prend vie d'un certain nombre de données
quantitatives
je trouve que parmi les épidémiologistes
qu'on entend depuis déjà maintenant
plusieurs mois
j'ai souvent trouvé qu arnaud fontanet
avait un discours assez assez constant
et et qui me semblait irrationnel
d'ailleurs comme l'épidémiologiste de en
train de ce lac de genève à peu près bon
tu entends le don le don il ya plus un
peu plus tôt pour je pense plutôt
l'extension du couvre feu si nécessaire
et à six heures du soir
si nécessaire ça a déjà été fait avec
quelques résultats
espérons que ça suffise et puis sera
hélas peut-être encore temps certains
disent que non il faut observe tout de
suite le confinement se suit pas
honnêtement à ces spécialistes est
compétente pour trancher comme ça je
serai pas dans le discours des yaka
fokon sur cette histoire
alexis qu'elles sont je sais pas vous
demander quelle est la solution mais
qu'elle est en tout cas quelles sont vos
craintes qu'elles sont
la comprendre la situation quand même
pas très réjouissante parce que on a un
ensemble de facteurs qui conduisent à
plutôt s'inquiéter
on a d'abord le froid plus malgré tout
plus ça va plus on quand même on se
donne est en train de se rendre compte
que cette épidémie très loin très liée
aux conditions climatiques et que s'il
faudrait ou s'il était en tout cas chez
nous deux
si c'était pas ça tant mieux yasar ya
aussi les codes et qu il ya les vacances
de noël gentilles et on verra s'il ya eu
beaucoup de conséquences
moyennement convaincant sous peu de
conséquences mais il ya sûrement eu des
conséquences me fait elle se voir si on
peut pas ne pas en avoir
et puis il ya ce fameux varien anglais
d'eau sur lequel on s'interroge encore
dont on n'est pas absolument sûrement
factices
ce qu'on regarde ce qu'on va en
angleterre même s'il est vrai que il
faut prendre en compte aussi le fait que
en blu ray home unis pendant des mois on
n'a rien fait
c'est à dire que ce que paie aujourd'hui
angleterre c'est sûrement pour une
partie de varier en anglais mais aussi
pour une autre pareille le fait qu'il ya
pas de masque on n'a pas pour finir que
bomba donc quand on fait rien moment ça
monte donc la question c'est quelle est
la proportion de varier anglais qui peut
nous arriver
et quelle est la proportion de l'absence
de précaution qui ne nous arrivera plus
puisque là nous les masques et tout ça
on les amants enfin bon si on met tout
ça bout à bout ça doit quand même pas
mal de raisons de s'inquiéter
alors après qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
vite confinement couvre-feu moi j'aurais
envie de dire vaccins au fond oui mais
ça ne mettra du temps mais certes mais
si on fait les choses bien sûr c'est une
manière pour une pirouette mais c'en est
pas qu une pirouette c'est que max il ya
il ya des confinement couvre feu ce sont
des constats d'échec couvre-feu
confinement plus exactement puisque en
fait confinement c'est le couvre-feu le
jour et la nuit le couvre feu c'est le
compliment la nuit donc ce sont des
constats d'échec ce sont des démons
action politique on n'y peut pas grand
chose quand ça va très mal on ferme
et quand on ferme il faut quelque temps
alors quinze jours trois semaines à moi
ça dépend quel stade ont fermé puis
après ça va mieux
et puis on réouvre ça repart c'est
mécanique la seule chose sur laquelle on
puisse espérer avoir de l'action
c'est à travers les vaccins parce que là
c'est de construire même unis c'est la
course contre les voir ils sont
néanmoins bien qu'il soit mis
ennemis et je sais qu'ils ont commencé à
vacciner ou plutôt qu'ils en sont
adonnés qu'une dose et plus de doses de
donner 1 et puis un autre vin bon bref
ces lapins honnêtement on a un sentiment
de panique quand on est moi j'ai de la
famille en angleterre très sincèrement
on a paniqué que et quand on est
néanmoins dans une situation extrêmement
et qui va durer ça ils en sont tous
maintenant très conscient et qui va
durer avant que le vaccin dtp les
problèmes britannique vous pensez que
c'est quand même mieux vaut mieux
vacciner deux millions de personnes dans
la panique quand big bang en vacciner
cent mille en ordre et dans la
discipline millions d'accord mais deux
millions dans la situation où ils sont
avec un an nhs pardon le système de
santé qui au bout du rouleau avec
beaucoup moins encore de deux lits que
nous en avons avec encore beaucoup moins
de lits de réanimation qu'on en a ils
sont dans une situation extrêmement
grave pour vraiment extrêmement ce sur
quoi il peut agir ils ont agi c'est ça
qui est important
quelques maisons pas pu agir alexis déjà
un peu avant avec un couvre feu ou armée
pour nous les laissons les leçon qu'on
peut tirer l'ex anglais ya cent ans de
musique ont appris avant eux donc celle
là on va faire revenir dessus on a eu
raison de le faire oui bon mais en
revanche ceux qui sont en train de faire
sur la vaccination pour l'instant je
croise les doigts peut-être que ça va
s'arranger ça a l'air de plutôt aller
plus vite mais enfin bon
on a pris un retard considérable il les
considère la cd non moi je ne suis pas
d'accord quand on voit par exemple avec
1026 bilal est un petit peu non mais je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec les
britanniques veut pas dire qu'on gardera
ce rapport de 1 à 10 j'espère bien sûr
on se serait cru même exactement parce
que je pense que l'accélération est en
train de se faire et elle va se faire de
plus en plus et que la crainte qu'ils
allaient y manquer de seringue
on a dit tout au tout et son contraire
et qu' il allait manquer de vaccins
apparemment l'arrivée le moderna est
sans doute à terme le vaccin britannique
fera qu'on ne manquera pas donc voilà on
aura à ma bon enfin je pense que pour ce
qui est le plus vulnérable parce que
vacciner tous azimuts moi je pense que
la stratégie qui était de dire bon ben
on vaccine les plus vils vulnérables ce
qui a été dit dès le 30 novembre
personne personne n'y a pas un médecin
généraliste je vous citiez de médecins
généralistes qui est dit mais non c'est
pas comme ça qu'il faut faire
tout le monde a dit assez bien de faire
comme ça il faut commencer par les plus
fragiles bon et puis après je suis allé
à commencer par les plus fragiles mais
au delà aujourd'hui on est plus à deux à
l'heure où commençait on est beaucoup
beaucoup plus que les anglais que les
allemands oui oui on préfère la
situation syndicale française
aujourd'hui vis de la france que celle
de mai sauf 4 il valait mieux est
d'aller en angleterre il ya trois mois
que la france
on a et on a eu la deuxième pack plutôt
que on a pris son nom de musée basque
ont été contraints eux ne l'ont pas eue
donc ils n'ont pas pris les mesures
grecques cela prenne en plein dans la
figure mais on peut pas tirer s'appuyer
là dessus pour dire qu'on a eu raison de
ne pas faire des vaccins ces deux choses
différentes
regardez l'italie s'il vous plaît
regardez l'italie ce pays sans état qui
est une catastrophe qui n'a pas de les
vérifier que fonctionnaire que nous
avons il arriva à vacciner dix fois plus
dingue je suis d'accord que sa balle
qu'on doit s'accélérer qu'il ya eu ce
qu'on va dire un rodage dix fois c'est
parade alors c'est une stratégie
je suis je rigole franchement attendait
ce qu'est ce que vous dites ce que vous
êtes levés quand vous c'est un
dysfonctionnement est enceinte c'est pas
vous non non c'est pas un
dysfonctionnement accidentelle
l'hypothèse que je fais on sait que si
on a craint qu'au fond n'est pas
beaucoup de vaccins et donc comme on en
avait pas beaucoup on a dit on va jouer
la carte des plus vénérables comme
effectivement le nombre de morts dans
les ehpad
alors que ça représente un faible
pourcentage de la population c'est 30%
des décès on s'est dit et que tout le
monde hurlait que dans les ehpad on
laisser les gens mourir qu'on était des
affreux et caetera et qui donc il
fallait s'occuper des gens dans les
ehpad et avec ce truc qui me semble
assez étonnant la nécessité d'avoir leur
accord dans une population où j'allais
dire là la conscience pour un certain
nombre
j'ai de la famille en ehpad vraie
conscience pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux fait que c'est la famille
qui doit prendre la décision
oui et qui est un bourreau et qui
beaucoup entendant ce qui se dit dans la
méfiance
d'abord alors moi je mettrais encore
c'est beaucoup plus le discours de la
méfiance sur le vaccin non ok toutes les
personnes toutes les personnes âgées qui
sont pas en ehpad alors on croit dessus
mais pourquoi est ce qu'on n'a pas fait
déjà fui bah oui bah c'est honteux et
aux mines mais les mets et les vaccine
pour ça pourquoi tous les pays font face
et si bien on n'aurait pas tous les
congés en cours de route
non mais quand même on les comprend et
ben non c'était pas bien donc foule dire
après et heureusement que ça change mais
pourquoi ça change ça change parce
qu'elles semblent de gens criaient et
crier très fort et que maxime elle
n'avait rien dit quand on leur a
présenté ses pas eu à dire
c'est par exemple c'est trop facile
les vaccinodromes tous les pays qui nous
entourent en ont fait 3 en novembre
et nous on attend fin janvier pour les
fermer parce qu'on a le souvenir du hac
synodaux n'est pas si mal passé personne
dedans donc je sais pas qui avait
personne ou d'un groupe moreau n'aurait
aujourd'hui vacciner tous les gens qu'on
a accusé pour l'achat d'armes serait
sacrément content oui donald ont dit non
il faut pas dire ça
il fallait tout faire simplement notre
admiration a voulu gérer la pénurie
et puis elle a eu peu mais elle a eu
peur je suis un grimpeur
des anti vaccins et donc on a eu
tellement peur de les brusquer qu'on a
raté des choses et puis elle a eu peur
des conséquences juridiques de ces deux
là et qu'elle a préféré ne pas agir
plutôt que prendre un risque mais
n'agissant pas elle a mis en danger des
gens pour se protéger elle même
je reconnais que l'équation judiciaire
est très compliqué pour les gens qui
nous gouvernent mais mais le résultat de
tout ça c'est qu'on ne décide de rien on
fait ceinture bretelles protection
protection surprotection la fin rien ne
se passe et sincère des conséquences du
compte si on a eu beaucoup plus de morts
dans les personnes âgées en france qu'on
en a eu en angleterre qui est vacciné
magnan d'allemagne en ce moment c'est en
train de flamber l'italie on verra on
donne rendez vous dans quelques temps je
suis pas sûr pour rebondir sur les
crèches aurait versé dans les prochaines
heures le fit économie fait état de en
tout cas de l'envié à bercy de un peu
stoppé réduire les aides la perfusion
d'une économie plombée par le vide
en gros on ne peut pas continuer à
confiner dans ces cas là si on arrête
les aides est fermé on peut pas
continuer à confiner fermer les bars les
restaurants les discothèques donc il
faudra passer par la case dans ces
cas-là à messia la case vaccin tout le
monde est bien évident que c'est la
seule porte de sortie avec ce virus
c'est un axe innée à l'arrivée une
vaccination collective montbronn une
limite et collective qui va demander
beaucoup de temps on va pas faire on va
c'est pas vrai on n'aura pas 60% du
minutes et collectives en france en juin
ça mais ça m'étonnerait je voudrais bien
savoir qu'elle est un pays qu'il l'aura
au mois de juin sur bon c'est pour ça
c'est évident perdu et c'est pour ça que
si on arrive à maintenir un équilibre
qui n'oblige pas au confinement qui
dépend aussi j'allais dire de la
responsabilité de tout à chacun
c'est bien évident c'est quand on entend
un certain nombre d'élus locaux
en var site et marseille mais c'était
quand même invraisemblable quelqu un
jour de lui menti devant leur
confinement
ben oui mais chaleureux quand on a
annoncé que c'était
couvre feu excusez moi à 18 heures ça
hurle et et madame rebeyrol à la
première en or mais quel scandale mais
c'est sûr mais enfin attendez et puis
après on apprend qu'il ya le variant
anglais dans une famille est un cluster
pas dans les quartiers nord dans les
chips quartiers sud de marseille 1 où la
famille est venue de londres passé noël
alors là tout d'un coup c'est la panique
et il faudrait continuer parce que c'est
dans un quartier chic que ça crée un
accord je dis simplement qu'on parle
toujours des quartiers nord et que pour
une fois peu parlé des quartiers sud un
succès que très jeune videur dans les
autres questions qu'on propose
alexis si on confine donc c est ce que
on ferme les écoles ou pas votre point
de vue bah c'est pareil en gros tout le
monde a compris qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'enfants porteurs sont porteurs
asymptomatiques porteur sain que
probablement il transmettait moins que
des adultes meurent faille transmettre
donc oui un risque après le coup de
fermer écoles est un coup catastrophe
catastrophique donc tant qu'on peut
éviter on est vite et puis le jour où
moi je pense que dans toute cette
matière là entre couvre-feu en
confinement fermetures d'écoles il faut
faire les choses quand on n'a plus le
choix ce sont des échecs
ce sont des constats d'échec donc un peu
chaud le fait pas ce qu'il vaut mieux ça
que que la catastrophe mais si on peut
l'éviter tant qu'on peut l'éviter une
fois il faut l'éviter est donc
l'histoire de la mesure préventive
ouverte ou fermée avant comme ça ben oui
c'est sûr si on s'enferme et consommer
sous cloches pendant deux ans il y aura
peu à la fin il y aura plus rien avant
il faut pas aller plus vite que la
musique
donc c'est vrai que c'est très difficile
bon jeu se met donc les écoles par
l'appareil tant qu'on peut il faut
essayer d'envoyer les enfants à l'école
pour les enfants
monsieur parce que des enfants qui vont
pas à l'école c'est une catastrophe on
le voit aujourd'hui pour les étudiants
un désastre c'est un dea sur le niveau
d'études sondea psychologique d'un dea
pour leur insertion professionnelle
c'est pour leur moral façade arrière une
bonne chose pour les enfants c'est un
désastre et eux à ce désastre pour les
enfants s'ajoute le désastre pour les
parents qui ayant leurs enfants sur les
bras ne peuvent plus travailler ou dans
des conditions acrobatiques
donc tant qu'on peut
évitez évitant demain on peut plus et
ben on fermera mais ça j'ai pas de
courir en avant doit lui en demander
toujours plus toujours plus et c'est
pour ça que je suis étonné moi que
certains élus locaux demandent du
confinement je pense une rente est
annoncé à nancy ils ont commencé à
vacciner un mot à marseille alors que
franchement ça doit être la dernière
extrémité
c'est bien évident tant qu'on peut
maintenir au maintien et puis le jour où
ils vont pourra pas battre moi je
considère que les locaux qui se battent
pour les vaccins pour installer des
salles de vaccination au poids bombay
sont là ils sont vraiment dans l'europe
parce que ça c'est un rôle positif mais
la fermeture c'est une protection c'est
un constat d'échec
on y est parfois contraint on y sera
sûrement contraint toute façon je donne
la parole aux internautes citent ch qui
justement sur cette question lui était
favorable à une fermeture des écoles un
confinement où les gamins continuer à se
croiser par centaines au collège où les
gens s'entassent dans les transports ça
n'a aucune crédibilité
le couvre-feu à 18 heures est une
demi-mesure ça ne suffit pas en tout cas
c'est ce qu'estime babineau
la dengue est un autre lecteur qui se
fait appeler le lecteur qui lui n'est
pas convaincu de l'efficacité du
confinement la question tous les cas
elle compose sur le site du figaro
encadrent confinement êtes vous
favorable à une fermeture de tous les
établissements scolaires et pour
l'instant vous êtes une large majorité à
répondre non au dernier pointage 62,87
et vous êtes plus de 80 mille à avoir
voté vous pouvez continuer à voter la
question et sur la page d'accueil et on
va demander à julie tu voulais remettre
dans le tchat
l'autre question cette fois-ci elle vous
est posée sur twitter faut-il organiser
une répartition nationale des migrants
sur le territoire français alors à
l'origine delà de la question il ya un
dossier à retrouver dans le figaro dans
les prochaines heures et un document qui
est le schéma national des demandeurs
d'asile et d'intégration des réfugiés
alors pour la faire courte le document
publié par le ministère de l'intérieur
nous révèle notamment que la région qui
abrite le plus de demandeurs d'asile et
la bourgogne franche comté que à moi
c'était en tout cas ce que j'ai lu dans
ce document officiel
je vous le mets à votre disposition m'a
cherché et qu'une des unes des régions
ils veulent le plus à laisser l'île de
france et les grandes métropoles
et là selon marlène schiappa cette
concentration de la demande participent
à la constitution des campements
insalubres sur la voie publique et
conduit des publics relevant de l'asile
vers l'hébergement d'urgence
généralistes ce qui n'est pas sa
vocation et dont voici la préconisation
de la présidente de france terre d'asile
la réorientation des demandeurs
franciliens vers les régions est
indispensable pour répondre aux besoins
de solidarité nationale dans la prise en
charge des demandeurs est ce que c'est
ça la solution la plus réaliste on
signale que les infrastructures ont
quasiment doublé en cinq ans elle est
passée de 55000 places à 110000
aujourd'hui il ya 178 1000 personnes
demandeurs devaient battre et oui je
pense que c'est la solution
je pense que je ne comprends pas qu'on
aimait autant de temps à apprendre cette
solution on va reprendre l'exemple de la
jungle de calais souvenez-vous où il y
avait plus de 10000
réfugiés qui sont assez dans la jungle
de calais qu'on a laissé s'installer
pendant plusieurs années jusqu'en 2016
ou 15,9 à ce moment là qui était
ministre premier ministre croit déjà en
2016 décide d'intervenir et de mettre
les gens dans des différends autobus et
de les répartir sur différents centres
en france
toutes les associations hurler dans dix
ans mais c'est scandaleux puis de toute
façon ils vont revenir
ils veulent pas s'en aller dans l'orne
ils veulent pas s'en aller dans le
calvados n'y a rien à faire pour eux ce
qu'ils veulent c'est l'angleterre on va
les voir revenir alors il y en a qui
sont revenus je connais bien calés c'est
ma ville d'origine et chez de la famille
on a à peu près aujourd'hui entre 1000
1200 réfugiés qui errent effectivement
et où on fait tout pour qu'il ne se
réinstalle passé c'est évident dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles
bon ça veut bien dire que les 9000
autres on a réparti en france et je fais
lancer une étude parce que je pense que
c'est très intéressant sur trois ou
quatre villes où ils ont été mis pour
voir comment maintenant ça s'est passé
puisque on a quand même quatre ans pour
voir ce que ça donne je n'ai pas encore
retrouvé le 9 le neuf une autre sont
répartis entre 100 et je pense que c'est
la politique qu'à l'allemagne et c'est
une politique qui datent de 1945 c'est à
dire que tous les réfugiés allemands en
revenant en allemane ont été d'office
attribués dans les différents länder
dans un pays fédéral où la décision a
été prise et où on a gardé cette logique
là c'est comme ça que les syriens qui
sont arrivés en 2015 traîne en bleu
nombreux ont été systématiquement
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire
je pense que c'est impérativement ce
qu'on doit faire ainsi moi je pense que
c'est impérativement ce qu'on ne doit
pas faire c'est ça qui est bien il ya
deux façons d'aborder ce problème ce
sont 10 comme d'autres ismes font part
du même constat la région ile-de-france
est pareil sont submergés de réfugiés
même pas toute la région des états le
droit de fumer rejet de réfugiés au
point que vous avez raison de dire on a
multiplié des capacités d'accueil par
deux passés de 55 mille cinq cent mille
et que sur l'ensemble de la france et la
russie pas exclue
ces cent mille s'ajoutent a déjà deux
cent mille places d'hébergement
d'urgence occupé en grande grande non
par des personnes sans titre de séjour
c'est ce que dit didier leschi qui est
là donc donc des places en main on en
rajoute on en rajoute on ne rejoigne il
y arrive toujours plus de réfugiés
donc il ya deux solutions la première ce
que dit attristé quand on les répartit
un peu partout et de plus en plus et de
plus en plus
et puis
et puis on verra ce qui se passe et puis
on aurait plus en plus d'ouvrir bas de
votre nationale par exemple pas
forcément à barr garder pour que les
campagnes à ce moment c'est en train de
voter partout financière mais bon c'est
pas présent en tout cas c'est une
solution et on est du coup il en
arrivera toujours davantage et toujours
davantage on les répartit 'sera et on
les enverra toujours dans der province
plus reculées où ils s'ajouteront plus
d'autres arriveront depuis toujours mais
il n'y a aucune raison que ça s'arrête
les phénomènes qui nourrissent l'arrivée
des clandestins ne s'arrêteront pas donc
ça ne s'arrêtera jamais et donc on on
passera un autre temps faire ça e
est ce que les français le veulent je ne
le crois pas donc est ce qu'on est et on
arrête là il vous arrêter alors il ya
deux solutions compliquées lui nommé la
première c'est d'arrêter avant qu'il
n'arrive
il ya donc des choses en du bas valais
déjà on arrêtait bateaux en mer pour
ceux qui arrivent par la mer et on le
renvoie leur corps d'origine
c'est interdit par la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme mais il faut le
faire
ensuite on les regroupe quand il de pour
ceux qui demandent un l'asile ont leur
groupe dans les mains de départ sur les
fameux hot spot qu'on peut installer
soit au point de départ de l'autre côté
de materner soit au point d'arrivée de
ce côté ci de la méditerranée
[Musique]
administrativement sous contrôle jusqu'à
l'issue de leur l'examen de leurs
demandes car l'immense majorité de ces
demandeurs d'asile n'auront pas là s'il
faut le savoir
on le sait il ne leur ont pas un sur
trois mais leur immense majorité de
surcroît resteront ce sont des
demandeurs d'asile qui n'ont pas droit à
l'asile pour 60% d'entre eux et qu'ils
resteront pour 80% de ses 60%
donc on est en train d'installer
d'installer un système qui est
absolument hors du droit puisque on
organise l'installation en france de
gens dont on sait par avance qu'ils
n'ont aucun droit il restait donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut les arrêter avant
notamment les centres de rétention
admirative et là encore la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et la
cour de justice européenne nous
interdisent de le faire il faut revoir
sa série kloten l'ancien secrétaire
général du conseil constitutionnel
qu'est ce que cette version très
précises dans le figaro c'est possible
il suffit de le décider
pour écoutez le
les souhaits des électeurs des français
et la deuxième chose qu'il faudrait
faire qui est difficile aussi mais il
faut le faire c'est organisé beaucoup
plus vite le retour quand ils sont
déboutés
parce que c'est vrai qu'un gars qu'on
garde un an voire davantage voire 18
mois bah quand dans 18 mois on lui dit
ben non t'as pas l'asile entre temps il
a disparu dans la nature
on n'a pas le droit de le garder sous la
main bon donc il faut les garder sous
contrôle administratif examiner leur
demande et les renvoyer
si on ne fait pas ça ça votre système
sur un an deux ans trois ans quatre ans
50 désordre et dans vingt ans on aura
une explosion absolument colossal avec
une guerre civile c'est pas ça qu'on
veut non moi je ne suis pas d'accord du
tout avec votre scénario 1 se pense que
des c'est vraiment la solution il ya
qu'à faut qu'on sait des hotspots
je viens parce que je pense que ce n'est
pas faisable
ce n'est pas faisable d'abord parce
qu'il suffit pas de dire il faut revoir
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
et puis on va la revoir et puis on va
l'obtenir je vois franchement pas qu'on
ait une unanimité pour obtenir ce genre
de chose votre abonnement c'est brandon
référendum référendum sur le référendum
vous savez comme moi qu'on répond
rarement à la vraie question et qu'on
vote et nouveau d'autres choses la
banque voulant pas d'une fête à
référendum sur l'asile l'immigration
maintenant que vous savez ce qu'on vaut
les gens vont répondre donc là on peut
le faire en étant au km 6 si vous
souhaitez lors de suivre vraiment la vie
des français si vous ne souhaitez pas il
la suit l'avis des français il faut pas
faire de référendum il y à certaines
questions sur lequel je ne suis pas
d'accord pour suivre la majorité des
français où la peine de mort c'est pour
ça que je vous le citez enfin c'est pas
sûr sur cette affaire qu'elle le serait
encore c'est un autre sujet bon donc je
pense vraiment je pense moi que c'est
que c'est pas vraiment faisable
le discours si vous voulez sur le
scénario vous faites sur une invasion et
qui serait absolument j'ai dire
exponentielle tient comme le vario
anglais dans dans sa diffusion
je lis ou ce qu'elle parle dans ce
arithmétique si vous voulez mais je n'y
souscris pas et ce qui me semble c'est
pour ça que je voudrais que faire cette
étude parce qu'elle me semble important
c'est voir comment se passe l'insertion
de 2 c
immigrés qui ont été renvoyés sur
l'ensemble de la voie que je sache on
n'a pas j'allais dire déco défense il
continuera de de la même façon il saura
pas plus il sera pas plus titre de
séjour régulier chaque année oui on a
donc sens 150 170 demandes d'asile à
certains ça on peut considérer parmi
ceux-là 20me nous allons dès aujourd'hui
rugby et donc il reste deux cent vingt
deux cents soit 170 518 on va peut-être
30 auront vraiment l'asile et les autres
ne leur ont pas donc on peut les ajouter
aux 270 ça fait combien 300 320 plus
tous les clandestins qui se passe sans
demander l'asile uniquement indiqué sa
femme avoue 400000 personnes qui rendent
tous les ans dans ce pays
vous pensez pas que ça pose un pourra
juger problème en ces temps économiques
un tout petit peu difficile à ceux qui
potentiellement socialement 1,4 je ne
dis pas que ça ne pose pas problème
jeudi que en attendant d'avoir le
blocage et des et les hotspots avenant
temps d'avoir ça vaut mieux répartir
tels qu'ils ceux qui sont là sur le
territoire pour éviter d'avoir ces abcès
de fixation pour avoir cette
médiatisation avec des effets absolument
dramatique
alors si je suis d'accord avec vous que
la france ne peut pas indéfiniment
accueillir on va dire un demi million
d'étrangers tous les enjeux j'y souscris
très bien mais que pour le moment la
corde ont au contraire la meilleure des
choses à faire en attendant qu'on arrive
à un autre situation
c'est d'éviter ces points de fixation
ces conditions effectivement indigne
dans le guen ces gens vivent et qui vaut
mieux à ce moment là pour faire il est
réparti on n'est pas si loin là dessus
ça tombe de cheval à et partir et puis
ils n'ont commis que c'est de travailler
sion qu'on peut se poser c'est quand est
ce que les répartissant comme vous le
suggérez
on ne comment dire on ne se sépare n'y
pas la possible on ne sait où et
d'abuser de faire leurs spots à dire que
comme ya plus de problème il ya plus de
solution on va plus chercher sur moi ce
que je crains c'est que si on résout les
problèmes en mettant la poussière je
dirais pas sous le tapis mais loin et
bah du coup d'il ya plus de problème
jusqu'au jour le problème n'est plus si
ce que vous dites est vrai si on se
disait mon gant pendant deux trois ans
à partie puis dans trois ans on aura
tout notre système très très bien je
crains malheureusement que les
répartissent pour ne rien faire
moi moi je crains que si on attend
encore trois quatre ans on va avoir une
montée effectivement d'un vote
rassemblement national de plus en plus
et que quand il sera là il peut arriver
à prendre le pouvoir on a vu que ça
arrivait à des tas d'endroits et ben on
sera en situation extrêmement difficile
donc je préfère calmer la tension
continue et peut-être à réfléchir la
solution et comment la mettre en oeuvre
de vaud hotspot ou des droits de l'homme
ce qui va pas être simple ça ne vous
demandera sans doute beaucoup de temps
et j'aurais tendance pour une fois c'est
parce que c'est tout le temps c'est à
regarder comment procèdent l'allemagne
dans sa gestion de ce million de
réfugiés qui est arrivé et dont ils sont
pas si mal sorti
j'ai une dernière question qui est très
provocante je vous la pose j'ai couvert
de la crise migratoire 2015 en hongrie
mais les dons qu'il y avait
effectivement des temps partout il y
avait il y avait un bazar enfin c'était
une énorme crise c'est à ce moment là
les hongrois ont mis des mythes des
frontières et puis des frontières
physiques ils ont barbelés ils ont
demandé aux prisonniers de de fermer les
points de passage et le nombre de
passages grasset et les objecteurs or
bad
ils ont eu tort sur mes discours les
fêtes victor orban avait décidé ça mais
métis que oui c'est aussi la hongrie qui
en 1989 a ouvert sa frontière avec sa
taille pour permettre à toute une série
1 de gens d'europe de l'est de passer
par la hongrie par l'autriche
et pour arriver à tout le monde et pour
aller en allemagne et tout le monde a
applaudi à ce moment là donc la hongrie
a pas toujours été un pays qui qui qui
c'est qui ferme ses frontières la
situation de la meilleure dont vous
parlez ses organes qui les a prises à la
question des pourparlers cette agression
non je pense que dans le cadre de
l'engrais pour moi l'engrais est un cas
tout à fait particulier parce que ça a
été un grand show la même chose avec
étonnement un grand et un grand
territoire qui a perdu à la
fin de la première guerre mondiale les
deux tiers de son territoire et sa
population et qui est un peu comme la
turquie si vous voulez crispé sur ce qui
peut être sa disparition et que c'est
vraiment comment une obsession je pense
qu'on peut qu'on peut dire ça une
obsession nationale c'est une langue qui
n'est parlé que par eux c'est
extrêmement puissant j'ai fait des
collègues hongrois je suis allé en
dirigeable en hongrie donc d'accord bref
la dernière objection je vous fais gaffe
risque c'est que vous ne citez bon ok la
hongrie mais l'autriche
à ce moment-là a fait la même chose et
ça s'est passé en une heure oui mes
mails à l'autriche même en faisant ça
aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'étrangers important parce qu'elle est
il passe quand même ils sont quand même
là qu' il n'y a jamais une frontière qui
est joie de vote totalement fermée et
vous avez bien vu les attentats qui a eu
en novembre qui les a donc tout à fait
surpris voilà je crois que personne
n'est véritablement à l'abri et que
l'idée qu'on ferme sa frontière et qu'on
est à l'abri tout ça ralentit c'est
évident or les choses plus difficiles
c'est sûr mais ça passe quand même
faut-il organiser une répartition
nationale des migrants sur le territoire
français c'était la question composé sur
twitter et là vous répondez également
non vous êtes très négatif ce soir non à
la première question non à la deuxième
et à chaque fois dans les proportions
qu'ils sont comparables mais après
comparaison n'est pas raison
si tu nous disais il ya des instances
internationales pour ça c'est leur job
qu'on protège les populations sur place
chez elles les
pourquoi dans mon coin seach midi c'est
le chômage de masse pas de transport
très peu de travail et maggie sur
twitter les répartir ne réglera pas le
souci de l'incapacité à les accueillir
dignement le temps d'évaluer si oui ou
non ils peuvent rester alors ça c'est un
autre élément qu'on aurait pu voir mais
justement dans ce document que vous
n'avez qu'à regarder on apprend plein de
choses et notamment que plus il ya de
personnes plus les procédures de
demandes d'asile sont longues sur lyon
est donc exclue ça mais en fait la durée
des demandes d'asile a été réduite elle
était beaucoup plus lourdes que ça on
était à 3 ans considérablement réduits
parce qu'on a mis à mis plus de monde
mais ça suffit pas en tout cas le reste
est à lire dans le figaro sur le site ou
bien dans la version papier dans les
prochaines heures merci beaucoup et on
se retrouve demain même heure même
endroit avec guillaume roquette
[Musique]